accidentel ou criminel c'est la question
pour ces deux techniciens
d'identification criminelle de la
gendarmerie nationale des yvelines
accompagné par un pompier spécialistes
ils recherchent des indices dans cette
maison 24 heures après l'incendié
objectif découvrir la cause du sinistre
pour nous c'est pas laisser passer pro
criminelle on a respecté les gravats
quand je disais tout à l'heure il n'y a
pas d'odeur d'accélérant de carburant ou
de matières suspect après un premier
bilan avec le pompier cette intervention
est terminée pour les techniciens
d'identification criminelle
les plus connus sont de miami ou de
manhattan mais des experts sont aussi
dans les yvelines
cinq techniciens au sein de la cellule
d'identification criminelle de
versailles la majorité de leurs
activités trouver des indices à travers
des méthodes scientifiques pour aider
les enquêteurs notamment sur des
homicides
donc là on a fait une représentation
d'une scène une découverte de cadavres
donc les premiers arrivés souvent sont
les voisins qui sont qui alerte les
services de gendarmerie ou les services
de secours
une fois que l'on intervient la première
chose que l'on va faire c'est figé la
scène à l'aide d'un appareil photo
numérique
on va faire ce qu'on appelle une
triangulation prendre sous différents
angles la pièce et ce qui s'y passe
histoire de la figer dans un deuxième
temps on va faire un ratissage de cette
zone de la pièce entre autres pour
pouvoir marquer à l'aide de numérotation
les traces et indices qui nous
paraissent pertinentes et qui ne
pourront permettre de résoudre
éventuellement l'enquète ou en tout cas
nous permettre de faire parler les
indices en des indices sur des objets à
travers des empreintes digitales
retrouvées grâce à des poudres ou des
pinceaux mais aussi des prélèvements
biologiques pour retrouver de l'adn
je vais donc imbibé les couillons à
l'aide d'une petite goutte d'eau stérile
là je passe sur toute la zone où
potentiellement la personne à apposer
ses lèvres qui les lèvres dit salive qui
lie salive diadème autre type
d'intervention les cambriolages ou les
vols ici une plaque d'immatriculation
d'un véhicule dérobé vient d'arriver au
laboratoire il va être analysée donc à
l'est de cette machine l'acculent de
fumigation on va passer notre objet
dans la cuve
elle est un produit spécifique on va
passer sous la coupelle nous allons le
placer à l'intérieur et lancé son cycle
ainsi que qui dure à peu près une
quarantaine de minutes et qui va nous
permettre de révéler ou non s'il ya des
empreintes digitales sur le support une
fois la réaction chimique effectué
l'objet est amenée en selle d'optique
une fois qu on a appliqué notre
colorants on passe notre objet souvent
photos à l'aide de l'appareil que vous
voyez ici qui va donner une intensité
lumineuse et appareils on a un filtre
sur l'appareil photo
ça va permettre et d'exciter le support
et donner une luminescence de
l'empreinte digitale quand on éteint la
lumière de la pièce on voit apparaître
clairement la révélation d'empreintes
digitales en 2017 56 dossiers ont été
traités dans le laboratoire de la
cellule d'identification criminelle 170
gendarmes de brigade sont formés dans
les yvelines pour relever des empreintes
ou de l'adn sur des situations de petite
délinquance